comment est venue vote donc quand vous
avez senti vous avez eu un bon camp
pardon je sais comment comment vous avez
senti vous aviez un don ça ça arrive à
cannes alors lyon j'ai senti à l'âge de
12 ans 12 ans bien avant la mort de mon
père tout ça m'a gâché beaucoup de
choses et ensuite je me suis levé et
j'ai aussi dit je puisse pas par
moi que tout cacher ça s'est passé comme
ça j'ai pris donc est ce qui me restait
ma famille ma soeur aînée ma mère mon
nom que tout ça a fait du maintien il
faut me dira je vais juste 13 ans
c'était très dur c'était très dur parce
que on perd la moitié de sa vie
et ensuite j'ai des bons
ton papa tissage j'ai dit non mon papa
est juste à côté genevois et gêner les
descriptions commune était si elle
impose serviette avec
un cartable et un impair il a même
changé d'un père me montre
les touches prix les uns après les
autres fini j'étais pas quitté il me dit
qu'il m'a pas quittée qui me retrouvera
qui étaient là pour m'aider il faut que
tu fasses des études il faut que tu te
mettes à travailler
et juste ranger dray voilà
l'histoire est simple mais difficile
quand on perd quelqu'un
je n'en connais mieux ces moments là
c'est pas facile alors sûr j'étais pas
donc je leur ai entouré par des soeurs
tout ça donc ça allait ça ressemble à
quoi vos visions dix ans ces quatre
nouvelles personnes
j'ai deux phénomènes mais un phénomène
souvent sous forme de boucle j'ai la
mecque qui est allé je parle d'un truc
du site et le remonte donc je suis en
contact que joua les personnes je me
posais des questions en direct
j'ai comme une boucle il ne vous pousse
et c'est un genre de cercle ne mets dans
le blanc si ça tourne à droite tu sais
que c'est du positif certains à gauche
le point négatif
c'est les éléments qu'on m'a donné quand
je me suis donc retrouvé ce don là ça
que j'ai caché caché mes camarades parce
que certains étaient même média alors
qu'elles sont va voir qu'est-ce qu'on a
un truc je l'appréciais devenait
dangereux dangereux je me dis n'ya pas
de gens comme ça voulait se mettre à
côté de gaza dès que vous voyez
quelqu'un vous avez un ou sur ceux sur
certaines personnes quand je vois dès
que vous voyez quelqu'un vous avouer je
me dis cette personne est là ça
s'appelle anne y
certaines personnes arrivées en tout à
l'heure il m'a arrêté en fait dans le
dans le couloir et il demande un voire
deux côtés et il m'a parlé de quelque
chose alors je vous dis la vérité il est
incroyable je sais que j'en ai un je ne
connaissais pas donc il ne connaît pas
ma vie qu'est ce qui s'est passé hier
des choses précises sur ce que j'étais
en train de vivre en cependant est bon
après je sais pas ce qui nous est arrivé
parce que vous êtes un peu de transform
transcender vous aviez besoin d'eau de
choses oui mais il faut que je me lavais
mais voilà mais c'est incroyable ce qui
d'ailleurs il suffit de voir les gens
qui sont autour et qui le fréquentent
depuis des années je veux dire il a
quand même fréquenté françois mitterrand
il a fréquenté les gens qui étaient
quand même des gens assez rationnel un
profil différent on sait que c'était
quelqu'un d'assez rationnelle
c'est incroyable cet homme est
incroyable et si vous permettez
j'étais à lire à tout le monde jamais
pressenti j'en ferai jamais une cause à
ça voilà c'est ça y est simple il faut
le dire ça j'avais pas là jamais voilà
je sais ce que vient de dire pardon
vraiment mais c'est important de le dire
mais je préfère le dire c'est un an vous
avez six ans c'est le premier truc qui
vous est arrivé comme ça quand vous avez
six ans vous aviez prédit que votre
professeur vous se moquerait debout dans
toute la classe et que vous auriez 11
sur 20 un devoir oui et c'est arrivé le
professeur en soirée c'est ça qu'on m'a
dit comme ça ça a commencé comme ça et
au fil des années vous de monnaies de
plus de plus en plus crade claire voyons
jean est ce que c'est compliqué de vivre
avec ce don parce que c'est vrai qu'à un
moment ça doit être compliqué aussi non
les promettant aux riches après c'est
comme une voiture en s'adaptant
sais que j'ai de nouveau je me suis
adapté mais c'est pas facile
parce que si vous préférez
n'importe quel kingdom on voit les
choses ils apprécient moi c'est quelque
chose qui me vient mais que je demande
pas mais ça vient donc j'ai jamais de
l'imprévu viendra alors il paraît que
vous dites toujours vous demander
d'aller demander c'est parce que pas et
alors ce qui se passe c'est qu'avec font
maintenant il ya plein de gens qui
l'appelle ou qu'il le voie pour lui
demander des choses est ce qui va se
passer ça ce qu'ils étaient il dit je
vais demander je te tiens au courant on
va raconter une histoire me dit si c'est
vrai pareil qu'un jour vous avez fait
arrêter le vont enfin c'est cesser mon
ami jean claude darmon qui m'a même
raconté sa vie est-ce que vous pouvez
nous raconter cette histoire ben oui il
veut partir donc le 10 janvier la
tempête tout ça le truc et je les écoute
14h je crois c'est f
ça s'arrête je peux pas annuler ses 10h
14h à l invité du foie ne pas m'appeler
je suis assez
je suis pas mou du genou vous avez vous
après que je suis assez pas décisif mais
après j'ai eu quatre heures je crois que
c'était 14 heures ça s'arrête et un
soleil bas ci
et là il est parti de là payent par
tiers et après juste après il ya une
tempête incroyable et c'est quoi cette
histoire de marcotter aussi une histoire
de barbecue il y avait du vent vraiment
et c'est quoi la regrettée je racontais
il y avait du vent il
[Musique]
est incroyable ouais tout volé les
assiettes et l'été mehdi fait quelque
chose j'aime les faits moi que je vais
demander tous les domaines ce sera la
première fois ce côté-là
chili mais attention je peux plus
revenir si c'est à dire oui
attention je ne pourrai jamais revenir
ne me demande pas à près de revenir
vas-y
il de vous le dire le vent s'est arrêtée
alors à l'instant t presque c'est pas ça
c'est qu'on a prouvé de chaleur mais
diffus revenir r1 ce qui ne se passe je
peux pousser sa est le plus c'est fou
comme vivre et se baigner comme jamais
et alors si je ne peux plus alors vous
saurez que les jamais fait ça mais c'est
fou ça certes on à gauche c'est négatif
consistant à droite c'est possible être
quand vous voyagez en effet si vous
pensez qu'il va encore se marier
alors d'ailleurs est-ce que c'est du
positif et du négatif on ne sait pas non
mais est-ce que les gens ça doit être
compliqué quand même dès que vous voyez
quelqu'un vous sentez un truc ou bien
c'est sûr certaines personnes là voilà
nicolas nous a dit qu'il vous aide vous
l'avait interpellé tout à l'heure est ce
que par exemple quand vous voyez les
gens autour de la table il s'y est ce
que vous avez tout de suite vous avez un
truc qui vous dit ah oui y'a un truc
mais lorsque j'ai une chose que je ne
donne jamais spectacle est bien sûr et
j'ai tour vielles toutes les émissions
c'est vrai c'est grâce à mes amis que
j'ai dit je
m'aperçois que j'ai vu l'émission simple
et non merci j'ai toujours refusé
jusqu'à maintenant parce que vous donnez
un spectacle c'est pas bien mais c'est
compter l aloé divine pour moi moi je
vois les gens je les prends et après
j'ai eu à côté de ça comme j'ai fait
mais je suis servir quelqu'un jeu sans
nous dire jeu sans nous dire il ya des
choses que vous sentez sur certaines
personnes qui sont nous dire quoi ici ou
pas du tout oui certains n'ont ils pas
ce qu'il fout mais elle est un petit peu
je supporterai incontrôlable parce que
j'ai tellement de monde autour de la csn
ya trop de trop d'infos et si je vois
quelqu'un qui est vraiment un truc j'ai
envie d'écouter voir si on peut se voir
après bien sûr et je vais les voir la
faire s'arrêter les vrais gens quand
vous dites je vais demander vous
demander à qui mais voilà
alors moi je sais pas et je n'ai pas une
tête
au ciel
comment vous fassiez des divers
jeux demandent s'ils disent que je peux
le faire ici
s'il est vrai j les ouïes de films
est-ce que vous avez parfois la police
ou la gendarmerie quand il ya des col
caisse ou quand il ya des disparitions
par exemple d'enfants ou de personnes
est ce que vous pouvez les aider vous
voulez retrouver m'appeler oui il m'a
plu c'est bamba il ya quelques années on
m'appelait c'était un enfant trouvé
pages et des indes en ville et là il est
pas loin vous êtes à 50 m je le trouvais
j'ai eu un cas ou deux
comme ça je vais bien ma télé je suis là
pour être dans la transparence voilà
c'est ça a fonctionné oui parce que
quand thomas moi ton moment trois mois
est purement je te détails
ouais j'ai dû malheureusement
malheureusement et puis d'un coup j'ai
dit non elle est vivante encore je me
rappelle c'est un cadeau
week est bon quand vous ressentez
quelque chose de négatif sur une
personne est ce que vous lui dites ou
est ce que vous le gardez pour vous ça
dépend
si vraiment si c'est important si je
vais vous permettez aux risques 2 au
risque 2 parce que je merde
vous l'aviez sans titre
[Rires]
mais c'est parti
vous abonnez vous allez vous faire virer
[Rires]
oui je voudrais pas mal ici a dit jean
jé pendant
vous me répéter la question car vous
ressentez quelque chose de négatif est
ce que vous le dites à la personne où
est ce que vous le gardez pour vous
c'est du vent si c'est vraiment négatif
tu sais pas si on a des risques de
dépendance avis tous âges et des vous
permettez je touchais vous dire au
risque de vous déplaire mais je préfère
vous le dire avant de comparer après
parce que peut-être on peut prévenir oui
prévenir que guérir je me suis arrivé à
ressentir si quelqu'un a une maladie
grave par exemple notre maladie
principalement à la cop16 voir et c'est
là que je suis
vigilant oui alors dans le livre vous
racontez votre contact avec françois
mitterrand il paraît aussi par exemple
la maison blanche vous a déjà appelé les
américains comment ça se passe dans ces
cas là c'est le président américain
lui-même ancien allié non vous voyez
j'ai un président en échec in town je
revends mon qui en a parlé dès lire des
e livres puisqu'il y avait moi et qu'il
tony vous demande quoi alors mas il
avait envie s'il a vu un cigare non
c'était la fameuse histoire en est on
connaît tout ça voilà
c'était quelque chose ça marrant parce
que si j'ai deux minutes face à lézat
d'exhorter les bonnes parce que je crois
que si tu es années 2000 j'ai peu
importe on était que tous les deux
jean-paul avec gérard
longuet
j'ai ramé dit oh là là si c'est bon on
va passer le réveillon ensemble
jour de l'an mais il est exclu du
jeu vidéo l'âge gérard sa part
l'américaine sa part l'américain je peux
pas jurer pas au message avant a dit
certain
qu'il y avait la fameuse histoire de
monica levinsky paraît il me dit voilà
on te propose de
on te proposait on te paye le voyage tu
veux être comme ça amenez moi qui viens
d'en parler je regarde année maintenant
moi il me dit jimmy quoi mais il aller
là-bas pour te remercier pour la faire
côté je distinguerai de suite si vous
refusez ça se paye pas c'est maintenant
le voir john blow oui pour me remercier
j'ai dit non je suis dit non sinon j'ai
jamais fait ça que je ferais jamais
parce que je pense déjà aux êtres qui
sont inférieures à nous si l'accès je
ferai le maximum je nomme non non pas
c'est une personne
personne pourquoi ces pages en omaha
vous avez appelé fuite un temps pour un
chanteur qui est décédé dans une grand
truc
que j'avais sorti d'affaires veut
mettre loue son visage je ne peux pas me
parler d'inovia les comprend et qui
vivait à lait des animaux comme je sais
qu'il y avait un problème comme ça je
dis sortira
oui mais vite et j'ai dit non toujours
j'ai toujours refusé
principalement parce que c'est pas que
je prends pas d'argent je sais ce choix
de la non jean yanne autre histoire
qu'on voulait évoquer avec toi c'est
nicolas qui va en parler il ya une
anecdote de l'entre-deux tours avec
françois mitterrand c'est françois
mitterrand s'était 1 donc c'était un
président en 1981 avec l'histoire de
communicatrice
vous demandez il vous demander conseil
et à un moment donné une histoire de
joaillerie que vous avez et françois
mitterrand dans le monde ce gris gris
entre entre les deux tours bon
essai si vous cette histoire en plus on
l'a retrouvé
on l'a retrouvé j'ai le retrouver sont
vraies alors
cité on va faire un flashback et dans le
temps un ami comme ça il hésité à se
présenter il avait se représenter il me
dit l époque j'étais instituteur
spécialisé
je me suis pop et de la manche
vraiment
j'étais malheureuse est d'aider des
déficients intellectuels aussi donc il
était passionné par ce que je faisais
et avait même proposé est magique mais
il petit j'avais monté un truc un cap
personne n'y croirait même pas moi c'est
le président et amandine et me dit je
dois me présenter c'est d'apprendre
celui-ci stephen je pouvais faire passer
les retrouver là
je sais pas comment faire si je
je renouvelle le mandat où je ne le
renouvelle pas
à dire
des petits sourires et je dis parce que
je sais que vous allez renouvelé mais
qu'est ce que vous avez toujours dans la
main je lis ce dernier s'éteint c'est un
grigri jeu pourtant je suis pas gagné
c'est un enfant et un jeune qui marche
pas ici me dire côté je vous le donne m
j'ai toujours là mais il m'a dit si je
vous demande de me le prêter
si oui je vous prête je voudrais le
récupérer
alors mis d'accord
je m'en rappelle plus ouvert mais je
voulais retrouver sur vous et je vous la
fais pas c'est parce qu'on l'a retrouvé
tintin n'a fait le libre
et
gilly a écouté l'émission et à telle
heure à telle heure d'accord éléments
précis on va se donner une heure
vous allez prendre de la main gauche m'a
donné j'ai le mettre dans la main droite
voilà est d'accord ou japonais comme ça
parce que moi ça me permettre de lancer
leur sur vous une attraction qui va être
très positive
même édifice que joyeux leurs familles
je vais bien
l'instance avait comme c'était lyon bien
appliquée
parce qu'ils ont à nouveau qu aux
trotteurs pas si l'intrus
et circle annoncé qu'il se représentait
hormis tout repos les hommes politiques
attention la salle à bercy il a voulu me
voir après harper et julie la fille
aînée ahmadi
vont pas voulait venir j'y perds c'est
d'y croire il n'est pas moi sur juste
gens avant de me libérer est-ce que vous
ici où josé posé la question tout à
l'heure vous est ce que par exemple si
quelqu'un vous poser une question sur
lui vous pouvez lui répondre même si en
dehors ou pas du tout sait on vous pose
des questions d'avoine d'orge et le voit
pas sérieux je pense que la réponse
appartient à la personne à qui je vois
bien sûr je n'en a jamais respecté ce
que vous aimeriez savoir la même source
en ce sens qui vous répond donc voilà
parés de boulleville est-ce que j'ai les
cocus par exemple
c'est pour commencer puis voilà
moi je dis des choses
à leur dire les choses est ce que
benjamin castaldi va va pouvoir arranger
les choses avec son banquier
très important est-ce que béatrice va
avoir l aller sur un gros casting en ce
moment parce qu'elle va avoir le rôle c
voilà je vous pose des questions est-ce
qu isabelle
il avait ce que je sais que vous parlez
avec les gens de l'au delà
vous pouvez les voir aussi ici non mais
voilà vous savez peut-être des questions
j'ai converti serez vous à votre
question où est ce que je vais pécho ce
soir
j'ai pas besoin de gens pour te dire moi
je te dis que c'est donc oui c'est une
question ma j'ai ma grand-mère chérie
qui est parti en septembre et il ya
quelques jours j'ai elle a interrompu
j'ai l'impression qu'elle a interrompu
un de mes rêves pour me dire quelque
chose et j'avais confiance dans mon rêve
que c'est n'avait rien à voir avec mon
rêve et comment j'arrive à savoir si
vraiment elle a essayé de rentrer en
contact avec moi ou c'est juste mon
esprit mon cerveau parce qu'elle me
manque voilà en gros
recrutement le point de voir mourir le
couesnon lucienne vous habitez lucienne
lucienne lucienne lucien lucienne
lucienne d'accord
si votre rêve le rêve presque une
réalité
l'appli son chemin pour aller ailleurs
elle de vous dire que rien n'était
facile pour elle l a pas cédé elle a
passé des moments très difficiles
et vous le savez
mais maintenant à trouver la quiétude et
la tranquillité est là pour trouver
quelqu'un qui était cher qu'elle
attendait depuis longtemps
il me dit vous diront comme ça je suis
maintenant bien et dites lui dites lui
que là où je me trouve je suis en pleine
libera surtout wii ne pleure pas ne peut
leur part ne pleure pas parce que j'ai
juste à côté de toi merci de parler de
moi ça me fait du bien mais surtout
sache que je suis bien là où j'ai trouvé
titus est là au projet temps des
diplômes
par deux hommes non mais si oui il veut
dire un truc à jouer oui jean jé je vais
vous poser une question très simple je
dois marié il ya des obstacles en
permanence
la question les yeux dans les yeux jean
vais-je enfin me marier cette année
ça fait des années qu'on attend depuis
des mois bien répéter les questions gens
je dois marié il ya des obstacles
vais-je enfin me marier cette année avec
sato gens
n'ont pas ce que vous faites deux pas en
avant trois pas en arrière je suis dit
oui parce que moi donner vous voulez
vous voulez vous voulez mais en fait on
vous pousse aussi vous poussez vous même
vous allez le faire à
jouer un petit peu plus tard mais ça
fait longtemps quand même là
et ces jours ci non non non dans l'année
où dans la wii
c'est pas ça qui est un grand voyage
il va partir en voyage et les faire
que c'est beau la vie mais
retrouver deux personnes après oui
autour de vous ce biais de revoir des
personnes que vous imaginez plus que les
exister ou quick est ce que vous pouvez
dire ce voyage ce sera quelque chose
d'important pour vous il va partir
longtemps pour savoir pour les vies
parce que divisés maintenant aujourd'hui
d'une stabilité à une tranquillité à
serein parce qu il y en a marre j'ai
fait un petit peu je sens faire du
pointillisme parce que des fois vous
êtes ayant un déficit je n'aurais pas dû
faire aujourd'hui c'est clair c'est net
et sans bavure voilà c'est vrai que
c'est que là vous y allé et la personne
veut dire ça y est merci jean
franchement c'est vrai ce qu'il dit ou
pas tout est vrai c'est incroyable des
gens comme en c1 c'est un bonheur je moi
je les ai vus là je veux un truc avec
lui tout de suite j'ai passé je jouais
mais cui moi j'ai des macros m je pense
qu'elle est tout le temps avec moi et
est ce qu'elle est avec nous là à
l'ordre public non mais quelque part je
suis persuadé qu'il ya autour de moi
grand mère elle est tout le temps avec
moi
s'appelait simone d'accord
mais c'est avoir la réponse bah oui la
sonorité weepu élincourt puisqu'avant
elle dit je n'ai jamais quitté il le
sait en plus de retrouver un enfant qui
est quelqu'un de jeune et qui m est
décédé elle a retrouvé là-bas pour une
chercherait et et là où elle se trouve
elle est en plein pays tu lis sérénité
elle dit simplement la chose suivante je
suis je suis bien j'ai eu un passage qui
était plus difficile il le sait un mois
donné mais là je suis très très bien et
à même de vous répondre vous sentirez la
première intuition qui viennent la
première chose qui viendra ce sera sa
réponse mais les biens est toujours pris
le goût à elle dit je n'ai jamais quitté
j'ai toujours été là je retrouvais de
personnes dont une amie qui
[Musique]
il a vu six là je suis très bien
dit oui
et que tu continues je vous fait à base
de blé pas si vous n'avez pas tout donné
ça c'est vrai
et de continuer parce que vous avez
la publicité il faut en galice rsa faut
qu'ils aient confiance en lui ils ont pu
parfois il ya un voyagiste ranger away
très loin
dans le temps passé par le royal chaque
genre de petite dernière question déjà
est ce que vous sentez que je vais être
encore sur cette chaîne l'année
prochaine
là il ya tant de propositions aux six
nations sont confinés oui je serai là
oui et il années après et en a signé
trois
donc tout va bien donc tu reviendras
nous voir
ça c'est la bonne nouvelle mais merci
jean genre va recevoir gabriela talent
dans un instant le porte parole du
gouvernement
est-ce que emmanuel macron va être réélu
et oui oui
c'est les sondages où c'est toi qui
merci